Godzilla: King of the Monsters is set to follow
up a film that reimagined cinema's favorite
fire-breathing behemoth — and left everyone
with plenty of questions, like: How does the
movie connect to its predecessors?
And, is Godzilla really the king, or is he
just some scaly-ass poser?
Don't worry — we've got the answers you're
looking for.
New faces, returning stars
A host of stars are joining the Godzilla family
for King of the Monsters.
The star-studded cast includes The Conjuring
franchise veteran Vera Farmiga as paleobiologist
Dr. Emma Russell, Stranger Things darling
Millie Bobby Brown as Madison Russell, and
Friday Night Lights alum Kyle Chandler as
animal behavior expert Dr. Mark Russell — Emma's
ex-husband.
Though there are more than a handful of new
characters to meet in Godzilla: King of the
Monsters, the film doesn't go without a few
returning favorites.
The actors returning for King of the Monsters
include Ken Watanabe and Sally Hawkins.
Watanabe slips back into the crisp white lab
coat of his Godzilla character Dr. Ishiro
Serizawa, a scientist at the crypto-zoological
organization Monarch.
Hawkins will be back as Serizawa's right-hand
woman Dr. Vivienne Graham.
Another actor coming back for King of the
Monsters?
Godzilla himself.
Professional stuntman T.J.
Storm reprises the monstrous role in a motion-capture
performance.
Family, rescue, and monsters
The vast majority of sequels use the ending
of their direct precursors as a springboard
to launch into new narrative territory.
Godzilla: King of the Monsters is no exception.
Set in 2019, five years after 2014's Godzilla,
King of the Monsters centers around the members
of Monarch as they go head to head with a
"battery of god-sized monsters" — and by
that, we mean Godzilla and his three foes
Rodan, Ghidorah, and Mothra.
Mankind once believed the "ancient super-species,"
collectively known as Titans, were the stuff
of fiction.
The Titans are all too real — and threaten
humanity's existence when they rise to fight
for dominance.
Godzilla: King of the Monsters also sees Dr.
Emma Russell and her daughter Madison get
kidnapped by a mysterious organization that
wants to use Emma's intellect and inventiveness,
as well as Madison's "strange connection"
with Mothra, for nefarious purposes.
Emma feels humans and Titans can co-exist
peacefully, but after experiencing a great
loss, her ex-husband Mark doesn't agree.
Despite holding a negative view of the monsters,
Mark teams with Monarch's Dr. Ishiro Serizawa
and Dr. Vivienne Graham to rescue Emma and
Madison.
The terrible trio
Godzilla: King of the Monsters will bring
Mothra, Rodan, and Ghidorah back to the big
screen, and we've got the skinny on who the
three creatures are and how they'll be depicted.
A colossal moth-like being, Mothra will be
both beautiful and deadly in King of the Monsters.
Director Michael Dougherty aimed to give her
a realistic appearance, including long legs
that help her fight against and defend herself
from her adversaries.
Rodan, on the other hand, is a pterodactyl-like
monster, described by Dougherty as a "massive
A-bomb [and a] bit of a rogue" with incredible
physical power.
Dougherty elaborated:
"You never quite know where his loyalties
lie.
Godzilla's more of a lumbering, plodding presence;
it takes him a couple of days to destroy a
city like Tokyo.
Rodan can level it without even thinking."
As for Ghidorah, the three-headed dragon beast
is Godzilla's ultimate nemesis.
That each of his heads has "its own different
personality" — one alpha and two "lackeys"
— makes Ghidorah even more formidable than
Godzilla's other challengers.
"Good thing he's on our side."
The title of Godzilla: King of the Monsters
tells audiences all they need to know about
the monster's ranking in the Titan hierarchy:
he's the big kahuna, the grand poobah, the
top banana.
But what about where Godzilla stands on the
hero-villain binary?
As Bradley Whitford's Dr. Stanton states in
one of the film's trailers, Godzilla is on
our side," and can help save mankind from
being eradicated as soon as Monarch sets him
free.
Though Godzilla isn't out to harm humans,
not everyone is totally willing to consider
him the good guy.
O'Shea Jackson Jr., whose character Barnes
leads Monarch's military crew, the G-Team,
told Fandango that Godzilla is a heroic protector:
"Speaking as a Godzilla fan, I always hated
those humans who acted like didn't Godzilla
didn't just save their ass.
What happened in San Francisco in 2014 [in
Godzilla], from what I can see, he holds down
the Pacific, so California seems safe.
So I'm down with that."
On the converse, Kyle Chandler, whose Dr.
Mark Russell has a "troubled history with
the Titans," isn't a fan of any of the Titans,
Godzilla included, explaining:
"They're mean, ugly, dangerous, and they've
caused havoc with [Mark's] family."
Looks like some will be hesitant to bow down
to the king.
That could be their undoing... or give Godzilla
the chance to prove them wrong.
Past meets present
Godzilla: King of the Monsters may be as fresh
as can be in terms of its time setting — taking
place in 2019, the same year of its release
— but it also incorporates elements of the
past.
Talking with Fandango, director Michael Dougherty
detailed that the concept of King of the Monsters
is rooted in the mythology that the world
belongs to the Titans, since they were on
Earth long before humans came along.
In his words, humans are "the invasive species,"
and the Titans are, quote, "the old gods…
the first gods."
He also shared that King of the Monsters gives
the creatures, according to him, "a more mythological,
almost biblical, backdrop" when exploring
their history.
Dougherty explained:
"These creatures were once worshipped by some
ancient civilization.
I really love that about the old movies that
Mothra was this deity.
It really opened up the mythology."
In simple terms, King of the Monsters sees
ancient mythology clash with the modern day,
bringing humans and god-like beasts together
at the same point in time.
It's a union partially motivated by a childhood
wish of Dougherty, who said,
"As a kid it, always bummed me out that dinosaurs
never actually crossed paths [with humans].
So I'm saying f--- that."
Filling in the gaps
The five-year break between Godzilla and King
of the Monsters leaves a lot of time unaccounted
for.
Though we can't say for certain whether King
of the Monsters will explain the in-world
events that went down between 2014 and 2019,
or how the film will address the gap, we can
assure you that another piece of Godzilla
content definitely will.
As of ten days ahead of King of the Monsters'
May 31st debut, fans can dig into Godzilla:
Aftershock.
The Legendary Comics-published tie-in prequel
graphic novel takes place in the time after
Godzilla and before King of the Monsters and
sets the stage for the sequel.
Written by Arvid Nelson with artwork by Drew
Edward Johnson, Godzilla: Aftershock continues
the plot laid out in Godzilla, seeing an all-new
monster, MUTO Prime, ascend from deep within
the planet and Godzilla battle an "unstoppable
primal instinct" that challenges his inner
strength.
The graphic novel also introduces several
characters from King of the Monsters, as Dr.
Emma Russell and the members of Monarch try
to put an end to the creature and attempt
to piece together the truth behind a past
tragedy "of apocalyptic proportions" that
is resurfacing again.
As Godzilla fights in a rivalry that spans
as many years as the Earth has been a planet,
Emma unravels secrets beyond anyone's wildest
imagination.
A meaningful message
King of the Monsters is about more than a
bunch of behemoths trading blows — in fact,
it carries a message about environmentalism,
the role humans play in the destruction of
planet Earth, and the importance of science
in our modern society.
Director Michael Dougherty told Fandango:
"In a time when, in our current climate, where
science is being constantly questioned and
targeted, the idea of creating a film where
scientists are heroes, I thought was really
important."
"So you want to make Godzilla our pet?"
"No.
We would be his."
Star Vera Farmiga even described the movie
as being more about environmentalism than
your average monster-filled flick, which is
what drew her to the project.
An Easter egg hunt
Nowadays, you'd be hard-pressed to find a
modern film that doesn't deliver fan service
in the form of Easter eggs.
They've become the norm in contemporary cinema,
with audiences practically squirming in their
seats at the thought of finding every last
hidden secret tucked inside a new release.
It should come as little surprise that Godzilla:
King of the Monsters will continue this trend
— but what you should know about the sneaky
references is that some will set up the future
of the Godzilla franchise.
Actor O'Shea Jackson Jr. told Fandango during
a set visit in 2017 that he was, quote, "nerding
out really hard" over the Easter eggs in King
of the Monsters, and said that fans will have
a blast trying to uncover them all.
Director Michael Dougherty piggybacked off
Jackson Jr.'s remarks when he told Entertainment
Weekly that the film will also tease the introduction
of another famous movie creature post-King
of the Monsters: King Kong.
Dougherty shared:
"It's not like we're bending over backwards
to introduce Kong, but there's definitely
some bread crumbs."
Grab your binoculars and a basket before heading
out to see King of the Monsters, as the moviegoing
experience sounds like it will double as a
massive Easter egg hunt.
Shared cinematic universe
Godzilla: King of the Monsters is no average
sequel.
It expands the revived world that Godzilla
set up and calls back to the old-school monster
movies produced by Toho, the Japanese company
responsible for 32 Godzilla films.
It also sets up a new cinematic universe packed
with monsters and centered on Monarch's undertakings
that will stretch across multiple releases.
King of the Monsters not only serves as the
sequel to Godzilla, but also as the next entry
in Warner Bros.' initial trio of MonsterVerse
movies, which see Godzilla exist among a wide
variety of other giant super-monsters, new
and old.
Additionally, director Michael Dougherty once
mentioned that King of the Monsters hinges
on something of a crossover event, as the
film unites the creatures featured in Toho's
classics.
Dougherty told the folks at Fandango:
"Outside of the Universal classic monster
movies, Toho is one of the first companies
to pioneer the idea of a shared universe.
They were doing it long before Marvel was.
Mothra was a completely separate film from
Godzilla when it started.
Same thing with Rodan.
So it kind of feels like things are coming
full circle [with King of the Monsters]."
A sequel
Before Godzilla: King of the Monsters even
released its first trailer, the bigwigs at
Warner Bros. and Legendary Pictures announced
plans for a sequel.
You know, that third entry into the studios'
Godzilla trilogy, the last piece of the first
wave of MonsterVerse movies, and the film
that King of the Monsters will tease with
its references to King Kong?
That one.
Aptly entitled Godzilla vs. Kong, the King
of the Monsters sequel has Death Note's Adam
Wingard on board as director, with many cast
members back in the fold.
The plot of Godzilla vs. Kong will center
around a brutal brawl between Godzilla and
the gorilla-like monster monkey.
The film — which stars Alexander Skarsgård
as "the leader of a military unit" as well
as Rebecca Hall, Jessica Henwick, Brian Tyree
Henry, and more — also focuses on humanity's
fight for its future.
Monarch's mission to discover the truth about
the Titans and a conspiracy that threatens
to end life on Earth continues
Make no mistake, though, there will be a clear
winner of the titular battle when it all goes
down on March 13th, 2020.
As Wingard once confirmed:
"I do want people to walk away from this film
feeling like, 'Okay, there is a winner.'"
"Long live the king."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.